Brittany wrote in saying hey David what
did you find most difficult about
immigrating to the United States as a
child I think it would be good for you
to share your experience because it is
very easy now to forget in the wake of
all of the xenophobia and
anti-immigration ideology from the
current administration that moving to
another country is not something that
people do lightly or take lightly this
is a really good point Brittany and I've
pointed this out before there is a
framing of those who are moving
immigrating as people who are just sort
of haphazardly uneducated Lee saying
what the hell I'm just gonna go to
another country and having done it
myself at the at the age of five where
it is easier to adjust than as an adult
I can tell you from personal experience
that it is really difficult and it is
arguably the most impactful decision
that my parents ever made on my life
sort of beyond just day-to-day parenting
decisions and the most difficult things
for me were I was dropped into a place
even at five years old you might not
realize the amount of sort of shared
history culture and knowledge that
five-year-olds have but it went beyond
just language I mean I remember being
the kid who was bringing weird lunches
to school and people were saying what
what is that and peanut butter and jelly
I didn't know what peanut what people my
parents didn't know about peanut butter
and jelly just sort of a little thing a
staple of the little kid lunch language
was problematic I remember at one point
in first grade when I was six oh and at
this point I'd been in the US for a year
already half a year something like that
kids saying what I thought was Joey said
Square and me not understanding Square
its shape I don't understand why we're
not allowed to say square geometry at
this point is not allowed and what they
were saying was joey said a swear and
that it those things just make you feel
like an outsider and it was a good
probably year and a half couple years
until my language got up to speed and I
sort of started to have more of that
understanding and that was a five year
old imagine as a 15 year old or as a 25
year old or as a 35 year old being
dropped into a country where you lack
the language the culture and that shared
sort of community history and it becomes
very obvious why many times immigrants
will exist mostly within communities of
people from the country they came from
or the religion they came from or some
other shared ideology because it is
extraordinarily difficult and obviously
being however many thousands of miles
Massachusetts is from Argentina what is
it six five six thousand miles something
like that don't remember now just being
far from family was also extraordinarily
difficult so yeah I mean Brittany I
think you're on to something that is
really important which is the framing of
immigrants as people who are abruptly
and uncaring ly leaving for the most
part the one place they've known the one
country they've lived in the entire
lives merely to try to show up and suck
up government welfare benefits or commit
crimes or whatever
these are life-altering major major
decisions and we should always remember
that that's the case we have a great
bonus show coming up for you today we
will talk about Sarah Huckabee Sanders
being completely unable to name a single
fake news outlet food stamps for soda is
it time to end the billion dollar
subsidy for sugary drinks I think that
it is and a story about a same-sex
couple carrying what some are calling a
miracle baby that some are saying is the
world's first all of those stories and
much more on today's bonus show I hope
you will please sign up please become a
member because membership is the number
one funding source for the program you
can get access to the bonus show by
signing up at www.movinon.com
slash david pakman show